welcome to rainbow six extraction
the new tactical co-op shooter game
where rainbow six operators are dropped
into alien territory
in today's walkthrough we're on a
mission to investigate anomalies
identified at the orpheus research
center in alaska
hq will provide additional instructions
we need new data on the parasites
underground network
it keeps evolving adapting plant auto
trackers on dormant nests
don't destroy them or will lose the
trackers
as a squad of three ella alibi and
sledge will use their operator abilities
to complete objectives
assist each other and obliterate
archaeans in their way
spinning up
that's a grunt easy for a nest to
incubate and bring to life
not so easy to eliminate in large
numbers converge on location
nice and quiet the enemy reacts to
intrusions in their ecosystems
including operators eliminate my target
so stealth tactics are the way to go
visual on nest place auto trackers for
our react scientists
[Music]
[Music]
activated
the parasite generates sprawl a
substance that connects the whole
ecosystem
alert and archaean and a nearby nest
wakes up too
our cans move faster in sprawl but
operators get slowed down
take my guy out the squad can use their
react light to see bioluminescent
properties on archaeans and in the
environment
[Music]
the contrast helps to better identify
targets
nest mapping complete a scientist just
gave me the thumbs up
good job identifying our key invariants
helps the team determine the best
approach to take them out
spotted a rooter it can immobilize
anyone in front of it
so sledge will swing around back
get out of there before the swarm
appears don't push your luck
airlock go
that was close here the team can regroup
and resupply
airlock doors will open onto the next
subzone which will be tougher than the
first
[Music]
we need tissue samples from those
archies and we need them gone
use your react blade
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's right there react blade do your
[Music]
thing
one down we're not done yet
[Music]
that's your target don't put it to death
just yet
get that sample we've located a spiker
it can fire armor-piercing projectiles
alibi deploys a prisma hologram
the squad can use react tech to go
further in incursions
the more intel they collect the more
tech they'll have at their disposal to
fight off this threat
it's all about teamwork to outsmart the
enemy vaticate that spot
reinforcing creating a choke point is a
good idea to increase the arc mine's
[Music]
efficiency
that's the way keep hunting that's the
react threat sensor
smasher incoming
wow that did it take out the leader no
leader for the archies to follow
another objective completed the squad
can either x fill up the extraction
point to bring home the latest intel
or move to the next airlock the third
subzone will be the most challenging yet
a true test of both practical team
strategy and operator reflexes
some archaeans are responding to an
elite as if they're communicating
no way we'd let them mobilize against us
hunt them down until the elite comes out
of hiding
that's the elite will show up any second
enemy located
we have an operator in stasis
an operator is now m.i.a i don't know if
you can hear this but we're mounting a
rescue
hang tight
you heard it a rescue mission is
underway
react still needs you
you